ask a leader a question that matters to
you this year from April 27th to April
29 over 400 participants will attend the
World Economic Forum on latin america in
rio de janeiro and discuss laying the
foundation for a Latin American decade
at the event presidents dignitaries and
leaders will stop by the social media
corner and upload video responses to
your questions what do you want to art
the leaders in Latin America pose your
question in video or text and submit at
youtube.com slash Davos we'll put a
selection of your questions to the
regional leaders in Rio when they come
to the social media corner giving you
direct access to some of the most
powerful and influential people in phone
go to youtube.com slash Davos today and
ask a leader